SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA HERE ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAPPIELLO CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO --
TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASSIE [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
A CORN.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE BORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO OUR FLAG
BY SENATOR BRIAN JONES
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
ETCETERA.
SINCE THIS IS WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH.
I'D LIKE TO COMBINE ST PATRICK
AND ST BRIDGET'S.
UP BOTH PATRON SAINTS OF IRELAND.
PATRICK WAS A BISHOP AND RUMOR
HAS IT THAT SO WAS BRIDGET.
I'M BRIDGET IS SAID TO HAVE
MIRACULOUSLY CHANGED WATER INTO
BEER.
SO WHAT MORE DO WE NEED.
SO GRACIOUS AND LOVING GOD.
AS WE CELEBRATE THE LIVES OF
PATRICK AND BRIDGET'S.
WHO BROUGHT HARMONY WHERE THERE
WAS CONFLICT?
TODAY WE PRAY.
MAY THE MANTLE OF YOUR PIECE
COVERED THOSE WHO WERE TROUBLED
AND ANXIOUS.
MAY PEACE BE FIRMLY ROOTED IN
OUR HEARTS AND IN OUR WORLD.
INSPIRADOS TO ACT JUSTLY AND TO
REFERENCE ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
MADE.
COM US INTO A QUIETNESS THAT
LISTENS AND HILLS.
MAY WE GROW EACH DAY ENTER
GRAZER WHOLENESS OF MIND BODY
AND SPIRIT A MAN.
COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OKAY -- CAM --
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY
[inaudible]
ALL.
AT THIS TIME WE WILL MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
MADAM PRO TEN ARE YOU PREPARED
IBM THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SO COLLEAGUES FOLLOWING THE
INSPIRATIONAL PRAYER THIS
MORNING.
AND IN THE SPIRIT OF WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH I WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO WISH
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG A
VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THERE ARE FEW IF ANY WOMEN ALIVE
TODAY WHO HAVE LEFT MORE OF A
MARK ON AMERICAN HISTORY.
ARE DONE MORE FOR WOMEN'S
EQUALITY TORY IS RBG.
AND IT IS ONLY THROUGH HER SHEER
DETERMINATION OF FORCE OF WILL
THAT WE EVEN KNOW HER NAME TODAY.
BECAUSE DESPITE HER REMARKABLE
INTELLECT HER MORAL CLARITY AND
HER RELENTLESS WORK ETHIC SHE
WAS DISMISSED AND IGNORED AND BE
LITTLE AT VIRTUALLY EVERY STEP
OF HER CAREER.
BECAUSE SHE WAS A WOMAN.
IS A WOMAN.
WHEN SHE ENROLLED AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX SHE
WAS ONE OF JUST NINE WOMEN IN
HER CLASS OF FIVE HUNDRED SHE
WAS RIDICULED FOR EVEN HAVING
THE NERVE TO TAKE THE PLACE OF A
MAN?
SHE BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE ON THE HARVARD LAW REVIEW
ALL WHILE CARING FOR HER TWO
YEAR OLD CHILD.
AND HER HUSBAND WHO HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH TESTICULAR CANCER.
AND WHEN SHE ULTIMATELY
GRADUATED AT THE TOP OF HER
CLASS FROM COLUMBIA LAW SCHOOL
IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE SHE
COULDN'T EVEN GET AN INTERVIEW
AT A REPUTABLE LAW FIRM.
BECAUSE SHE WAS A WOMAN.
AS A LAW PROFESSOR SHE BECAME
THE FIRST WOMAN TO EARN FULL
TENURE AT COLUMBIA LAW SCHOOL.
AS A TRIAL LAWYER AND DIRECTOR
OF THE GROUND BREAKING WOMEN'S
RIGHTS PROJECT FOR THE ACLU SHE
SUCCESSFULLY ARGUED SIX CASES ON
GENDER DISCRIMINATION BEFORE THE
US SUPREME COURT.
IN FACT IRONICALLY ENOUGH SHE
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF GENDER
DISCRIMINATION LAW IN AMERICA BY
ARGUING ON BEHALF OF MEN WHO HAD
BEEN DENIED GOVERNMENT BENEFITS
WHETHER IT WAS SPOUSAL ALLOWANCE
FOR THE HUSBAND OF A FEMALE
OFFICER.
IN THE AIRFORCE OUR PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTIONS FOR WIDOWERS.
OF COURSE SHE WENT ON TO BECOME
THE SECOND WOMAN EVER TO SERVE
ON THE SUPREME COURT.
AND NOW DESPITE HER DIMINUTIVE
STATURE.
EYES SHE IS TOWERING BY A
TOWERING FIGURE IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO IMAGINE
JUST HOW DIFFERENT OUR WORLD
WOULD BE WITHOUT HER TODAY.
SO IN RECOGNITION OF WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE AWARE IT IS ALL
MONTH.
ARE WE WANNA WISHER I WANT TO
TAKE A PRIVILEGE TO WISH.
JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND MANY MANY
MANY MANY MORE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TAKING THAT APPROACH AND FOR
THAT -- THAT
MOVING BIRTHDAY GREETING SENATOR
ARCHULETA YOU PREPARE TO AND
INTRODUCE OUR GAS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LATE IN JULY DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE GALLERY.
I'M SO HONORED TODAY.
TO LOOK UP AND AND SEE SO MANY
EDUCATORS THEY'RE IN THERE FOR
MY DISTRICT LITTLE LAKE --
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND THEY ARE HERE TO RECEIVE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF SCHOOLS
AWARD FOR THEIR OUTSTANDING
SERVICE IN THE CHILDREN.
THE SCHOOL TO WATCH TAKES CENTER
STAGE PROGRAM OUTSTANDING
PROGRAM RECOGNIZING KIDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND LITTLE LAKE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS HERE TO RECEIVE THE AWARD SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THEM IN THE GALLERY OUR
EDUCATORS.
WHAT WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO
THE SENATE CHAMBER?
ODDS CENTER MINING.
CENTER DO SURE GAS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT WELCOME TO THE
DíAS AND MEMBERS IN COLLEAGUES
IT'S MY HONOR TO WELCOME.
LEADERSHIP MORGAN HILL HERE
TODAY MAKING THE ROUNDS IN OUR
STATE CAPITOL PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A WARM WELCOME FOR LEADERSHIP
MORGAN HILL.
WELCOME WHEN I MOVED --
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR. FOR
MONTHS I'M SORRY UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF FLOOR SENATOR
GLAZER.
AT FOR PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENT.
I USED PRESIDENT MEMBERS WERE
ALSO BLESSED THE THIS MORNING TO
HAVE STUDENTS FROM FOOT HILL
MIDDLE SCHOOL FROM WALNUT CREEK.
UP HERE IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING HIM A WARM
WELCOME TO THE SENATE WELCOME.
YOU KNOW OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS
WILL MOVE TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE DEEMED TO
READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MARCH ELEVENTH
THROUGH THE FOURTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
SENATOR CHIANG UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO REQUEST TO REMOVE ESSIE
OUR FIFTEEN FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE.
DULY NOTED.
THAT SCHOOL NOTE [inaudible]
YES.
NOW MOVES TO THE CONSIDERATION
THE DAILY FILE.
FIRST UP A SECOND READING FILE
ITEM ONE SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU NOW MOVES TO THIRD
READING.
WE WILL TAKE UP ITEM SEVEN NINE
AND TEN ITEM SEVEN IS SENATOR
PORTANTINO ARE YOU PREPARED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES --
TODAY I PROBABLY STAND TO
PRESENT AT T. THREE WHAT.
CENTER POINT YOU KNOW I'M KIND
OF EXCITED.
TODAY -- CAN
THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
AND THEN WILL PROCEED THANK YOU.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO RELATIVE
TO THE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE MARCH FIRST INDEPENDENT
MOVEMENT IN KOREA.
MY APOLOGIES AND CENTER
PORTANTINO THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE AGAIN --
TO PROUDLY REPRESENTS AND
PRESENT --
SR TWENTY THREE WITH --
DOCTOR PAN WHICH WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH COMMEMORATES
THE ONE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY OF
KOREA'S MARCH FIRST INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT.
ON THE FIRST DAY OF THE THIRD
MONTH IN NINETEEN NINETEEN THE
PEOPLE OF KOREA PEACEFULLY
DEMONSTRATED FOR INDEPENDENCE
THIS INDEPENDENCE MOVEMENT WAS
CALLED MON SAY.
THE MOVEMENT WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
AND FOR TO INFORM THE WORLD THAT
THE KOREAN PEOPLE SHOULD BECOME
INDEPENDENT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE DEMOCRACY AND SELF
DETERMINATION PRINCIPLES OF
WOODROW WILSON.
THIS RESOLUTION HIGHLIGHTS THE
INTER CORAL PLAYED BY KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE MOVEMENT
AS MANY KOREAN IMMIGRANTS WORK
LONG HOURS AT ARGENT PEACH FARMS.
NOT ONLY TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES BACK IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRY.
I LEARNED THAT THE VERY FIRST
ANNIVERSARY CELEBRATION OF THE
INDEPENDENCE MOVEMENT HAPPENED
IT NEAR FRESNO IN THE CITIES OF
RIDLEY AND DIE NUBA.
AND THIS SIGNIFICANT EVENT SHOWS
HAS TO HOW HISTORIC OUR STATE'S
ROLE IN THIS AND OUR DIVERSITY
PLAYED IN THIS INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT.
I BELIEVE THIS ROUTE RESOLUTION
TRULY REFLECTS THE LONG HISTORY
AND CLOSE FRIENDSHIP BETWEEN OUR
STATE AND THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
CENTERS -- I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION Y. THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM LIVE CANNOT A FLINT
RIDGE FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION
FORD.
A SOMETIMES PEOPLE WONDER HERE
IN THIS CHAMBER WE HAVE
RESOLUTIONS WE BRING UP ISSUES
THAT PEOPLE SAY WELL THAT'S NOT
ABOUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT'S ABOUT SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
THE WORLD.
BUT WE ARE NOT ONLY OF COURSE
LEADERS IN THE UNITED STATES IS
THE LARGEST STATE IN OUR COUNTRY
BUT ALSO LEADERS INTERNATIONALLY
AND I THINK.
THE KOREAN COMMUNITY HERE SHOW
THAT A HUNDRED YEARS AGO AND
STANDING UP FOR INDEPENDENCE FOR
CREA OF WHICH COURSE HAPPENED
AND IT'S FIVE BY THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FOR RECOGNIZING THIS.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF THE API
COMMUNITY OUR HISTORY I THANK
YOU I URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PANTS SEEING
NO OTHER MIKE'S UPS --
UPS SENATOR RAZA I'M SORRY.
YES I AM THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO I ALSO STAND IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
FOUR REPRESENTS THE LARGEST
KOREAN AMERICAN.
COMMUNITY CERTAINLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA MAYBE A IN THE
COUNTRY SO --
I ALSO RISE TO RECOGNIZE OTHER
CONTRIBUTIONS AND IT'S
INTERESTING TO SEE THAT --
THERE OF A FIRST ARRIVALS IN.
TOWNS LIKE REALLY AND I KNEW BUT
THEY NUMBER WERE MY LATE HUSBAND
MIGUEL -- IS
FROM AND AND WELL ESTABLISHED SO
THIS IS GOOD NEWS THINGS THAT WE
FIND OUT ABOUT OUR STATE THAT
ARE REALLY AMAZING THEY'RE NOT --
THESE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR VERY VERY LONG
TIME SOMETIMES WE THINK OF THEM
AS RECENT ARRIVALS --
BUT AGAIN I STAND TO RISE IN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER FOR YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR HER TADO.
YES I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT AND
OF WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE.
FOR IN PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND
OF COURSE RIDLEY AND I KNEW BY
ARE BOTH CITIES THAT TIE
REPRESENT SO.
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S.
A CENTER PORTANTINO YOU.
CENTER BARGES.
I THINK YOU GUYS ARE MESSING
WITH ME NOW.
SENATOR GORGEOUS NO I JUST --
QUICKLY WANTED --
TO TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE FOR
YOU BRING FORTH THIS --
THIS ITEM AS WELL.
OUR SUPPORTERS WITH YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BARGES.
SEEING NO MIKE'S UP CENTER
FOURTEEN OUT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CENTER PORTANTINO.
EFFORT.
NO.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE UP THERE NEXT
WEEK CORRECT OKAY.
NO TO NOTE TO SELF REPORT YOU
KNOW YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WARM COMMENTS
ABOUT -- SR
TWENTY THREE I'D ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT I BELIEVE OUR
FORMER LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
FORMER SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY --
CRUZ BUSTAMANTE WAS ALSO FROM
DINU BUT SO THERE'S LOTS OF
CONNECTIONS TO THIS CAPITAL TO
THIS WONDERFUL MOVEMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SECRETARY WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD BY CAMBIADO
[inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
HI.
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PM ROTH AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY HAMBURG [inaudible]
OUR COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK HI HI.
THE LOTUS THIRTY SIX IV I KNOW
NOS THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SO CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
PORTANTINO.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM NINE
SENATOR DORADO ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT YOUR RESOLUTION PASS
ON FILE.
A PASS ON FILE.
BOB WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM TEN
CENTER CAP --
CAPRI OUR OWN ARE YOU PREPARED
TO PRESENT YOUR RESOLUTION.
PASS ON FILE.
OKAY WITH THAT THAT COMPLETES
THE DAILY FILE.
AND NOW WILL MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ANY COMMITTEE ANNOUNCED IT
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
ALL CENTER SKINNER.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
BUDGET COMMITTEE SEPT FIVE WILL
MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER THE
FLOOR ADJOURNS THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL MEET AT NINE
FORTY FIVE IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THANK YOU
SIR.
CENTER PAN THANK YOU --
BUDGETS OF ME NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
CONVENE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AT NINE THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
SENATOR WINNER OKAY [inaudible]
PLEASE YES
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE --
FOR WILL BE MEETING IN TEN
MINUTES AFTER GERMAN.
A IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WE ARE GOING TO RETURN BACK TO
PRIVILEGES AT THE FLOOR FOR
SENATOR ALAN.
BUT VERY VERY BRIEF MOMENT TO
LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT THE BOARD
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SUMMER
SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS IS HERE THIS
IS A PARTIALLY PUBLIC PARTIALLY
PRIVATELY FUNDED SUMMERTIME
PROGRAM FOR TALENTED ARTS
STUDENTS.
FROM AROUND THE STATE TO GO TO
CAL ARTS EVERY SUMMER AND HAVE
THIS WONDERFUL TRANSFORMATIVE
INTEGRATIVE ARTS EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE AND THEY'RE ALL HERE --
TALKING SHOP ABOUT THEIR THEIR
GREAT WORK PROMOTING ARTS
EDUCATION IN OUR SCHOOLS AND FOR
THESE WONDERFUL STUDENTS SO JUST
WANT TO WELCOME THEM HERE TODAY.
CAL ARTS IS AN INCREDIBLE
INSTITUTION.
WAS IN THE HOME OF THE THIRTIETH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND 90% OF ALL
ANIMATORS AT DISNEY --
GRADUATE FROM CAL ARTS.
IT'S NOT IN MY SENATE-DISTRICT I
CAN HIT IT WITH THE STONE IS NOT
IN.
OUR WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS SENATOR.
BUT COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT
ARE Y. CASKEY.
FISCAL AND BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE --
TO WILL BE MEETING FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER GERMAN IN ROOM.
ONE ONE TWO THANK YOU SIR.
AT THIS POINT.
WE WILL BE RETURNING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS.
AND IT AND THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR JOURNEY
MEMORIES [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
COLLEAGUES I ASK THAT YOU JOIN.
ME IN A DURING IN MEMORY.
A VICTOR MACKEL HANEY.
A PROUD OAKLAND NATIVE A
TALENTED DRUMMER.
A GUN CONTROL ACTIVIST AND A
STUDENT AT USC.
WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN?
TWENTY TWO NEXT MONTH THIS APRIL.
VICTOR WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED.
IN APPARENT ROBBERY ATTEMPT.
NEAR HIS SCHOOL USC HE WAS IN
THE PARKING LOT OF A MARKET WITH
SOME FRIENDS.
HE WAS THE SON.
OF MY FRIEND OAKLAND COUNCIL
MEMBER LYNETTE MACKEL HANEY.
AND CLEARANCE MEDICAL HANEY.
HE STUDIED JAZZ.
AT THE OAKLAND PUBLIC
CONSERVATORY OF MUSIC.
THEN HE WENT TO CAL STATE EAST
BAY AND TRANSFERRED TO USC TO
CONTINUE HIS MUSIC STUDIES.
HE VICTOR WAS VERY DELIBERATE.
IN CONNECTING HIS STUDY OF JAZZ
MUSIC TO ITS ORIGINS BY FRICAN
AMERICANS IN OUR AMERICAN SOUTH.
HE GREW UP SURROUNDED BY A
COMMUNITY OF ACTIVISTS BUT HE
WAS FINDING HIS STRIDE AS AN
INDEPENDENT ACTIVIST IN HIS OWN
RIGHT.
HE WAS AN INDEPENDENT SOUL.
MINETTE DESCRIBED TO ME THAT HE
WAS THE ONLY BABY THAT SHE'D
EVER MET THAT CRIED WHEN SHE
HELD HIM TOO LONG.
BECAUSE HE WANTED HIS OWN SPACE
AND I'M SORRY FOR BREAKING UP
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE LOSING MY
BABY.
A FELLOW STUDENT REMEMBERED HIM
AS OUT SPOKEN ANY PERSON WHO
CHALLENGED EVERYONE AROUND HIM
IN A WAY.
THAT WOULD ADVANCE.
OUR CULTURE AND THE CULTURE THAT
WAS SO DEAR TO HIM.
HE WAS ROOTED IN HIS MUSIC IN
HIS COMMUNITY AND IN HIS FAITH.
HE MENTORED TEENS BOTH WHEN HE
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND WHILE HE'S FIRST STARTED
COLLEGE IN THE EAST IN THE EAST
BAY AREA STILL IN OAKLAND THREE
MENTOR TEENS AT THE OAKLAND
PUBLIC CONSERVATORY OF MUSIC.
AND WHEN HE WENT TO USC HE WAS
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE CENTER
FOR BLACK CULTURAL AND STUDENT
AFFAIRS.
DID I MENTION THAT HE WAS.
KILLED JUST LAST SATURDAY NIGHT
[inaudible]
HIS MOTHER.
COUNCILMEMBER MACKEL HANEY.
ESTABLISHED OAKLAND'S DEPARTMENT
OF VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
AFTER HER ADOPTED GRAN CENTURION
HUGHES WAS ALSO.
DIED FROM GUN VIOLENCE IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND LYNETTE WAS
ATTENDING.
THE TRIAL FOR THAT SHOOTER IN
THESE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS SO
SHE WAS AT THAT TRIAL JUST LAST
WEEK.
HERE'S WHAT LYNETTE VICTOR'S
MOTHER EXPRESSED IN A PRESS
EVENT.
WHEN SHE IN CLEARANCE VICTOR'S
FATHER WERE APPEALING? TWO
POLICE HAVE.
THOSE WHO SHOT HIM OR INVOLVED
IN THE INCIDENT TO COME FORWARD
OR FOR ANYONE WHO KNEW ABOUT IT
TO COME FORWARD.
THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
VICTOR WAS ALWAYS EXPANDING HER
BORDERS.
HE IS NOT JUST A HOMICIDE NUMBER.
HE CAME INTO THE WORLD A DRUMMER.
HE COULD DRUM BEFORE EVEN COULD
SET UP.
HE BELIEVED MUSIC COULD HEAL THE
WORLD FROM VIOLENCE SICKNESS AND
ADDICTION.
AND HIS DESIRE TO BRING WHAT HE
CALLED MUSIC MEDICINE.
IS WHAT BROUGHT HIM TO UCLA TO
STUDY MUSIC OR USC POLICIES.
WHEN IT STATED VERY CLEARLY?
THAT STATISTICS SHOW THAT BLACK
AND BROWN BOYS.
IN THE AGE OF TEENAGERS TO YOUNG
ADULTS.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM GUN
VIOLENCE THAN THEIR WHITE PEERS
AND IN OAKLAND ALONE.
THAT IS A 63% HIGHER LIKELIHOOD.
BUT SHE ALSO STATED VERY CLEARLY
IT'S AN EPIDEMIC.
THAT WE THAT AMERICA CAN CURE.
AND SHE CHALLENGED US TO DO SO
AND HER MESSAGE IS TO DO WHAT
VICTOR.
TOLD HER.
AND TOLD THE STUDENTS THAT HE
MENTORED HE SAID CHANGE THE
VIBRATION.
SEND LOVE OUT AS A HEALING
ENERGY.
USE MUSIC TO HEAL.
AND SEND THAT HEALING ENERGY
FROM OAKLAND TO THE WORLD.
LET VICTOR BE THE REASON WE NO
LONGER HAVE TO ROB OR STEAL OR
TAKE A LIFE.
WE ALL WANT OUR NATION AND OUR
CITIES TO HEAL.
AND FOR THAT.
COUNCILMEMBER MACKEL HANEY HER
FAMILY HER CHURCH AND MANY
OTHERS.
WHO ARE WORKING WITH HER WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK AND USE
VICTOR AS THEIR GUIDE?
AND I HOPE WE ALL DO.
AND THEY HAVE SET UP A MEMORIAL
FUND IN HIS HONOR TO HELP FUNDS
THAT WORK.
THAT WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY
BOSS WHICH IS IN EAST BAY
NONPROFIT DEDICATED. TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS MASS INCORPORATE
INCARCERATION AND COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE.
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME IN.
HIS A DURING THE SESSION IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER FOR
THAT MOVING TRIBUTE AND
CONDOLENCES FROM THE SENATE TO
THE MEDICAL HANEY FAMILY --
SENATOR [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
ARE YOU --
WEIGHING IN ON THIS JOURNEY
MEMORY OKAY.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT HI
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM THE EAST BAY --
FOR THAT POWERFUL RECOUNT.
I THINK THE BANNER HEADLINE --
FROM THE COUNCIL WOMAN IN THE LA
TIMES SUMS IT UP FOR EVERYBODY
AND SHE SAID.
PERMISSION TO RE.
PLEASE THANK YOU AND I QUOTE.
I MISS MY BABY.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ON SPRING BREAK.
AND HOW MANY OF US REMEMBER
SPRING BREAK.
AT TWENTY ONE NOT A CARE IN THE
WORLD.
AND SO WHAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
AS WE DURING HIS MEMBER THAT WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE.
THE RIPPLE EFFECT GUN VIOLENCE
CREATES AND THE SENSE OF TRAUMA.
THAT THE BROADER COMMUNITY IS
GONNA REFER EXPERIENCE AS A
RESULT.
OF THIS YOUNG MAN LOSING HIS
LIFE.
HE WAS ONE OF ONLY A HANDFUL OF
BLACK STUDENTS.
AT U. S. SEES.
FULL OF MUSIC THE THORTON SCHOOL
OF MUSIC.
HE WAS IN JAZZ STUDIES SO HE WAS
IN THE CONTEMPORARY DIVISION ONE
OF ONLY A HANDFUL OF BLACK
STUDENTS.
THE DEAN HAS SPOKEN THE
PRESIDENT HAS SPOKEN PROFESSORS
IN THE SCHOOL OF MUSIC.
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE TRAUMA THE
ENTIRE SCHOOL IS GOING TO
EXPERIENCE AS A RESULT OF THIS
ACT OF VIOLENCE.
AND SO AS WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY AND HOLD OUR DEAR FRIEND
THE COUNCIL WOMAN UP. TO GIVE
HER THE STRENGTH TO THE NEED AS
A MOTHER TO GO FORWARD AS A
PUBLIC SERVANT.
AND SERVE HER COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF VIOLENCE IN ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF US TO BE MINDFUL OF THE
IMPACT TRAUMA REALLY HOUSE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
THOSE STUDENTS THE BLACK
STUDENTS ALL THE STUDENTS ON
THAT CAMPUS WILL FOR EVER BE
IMPACTED BY THE LOSS OF THEIR
TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD CLASSMATE.
ANSEL SOMETIMES OUR
CONVERSATIONS AROUND VIOLENCE
WHOSE COMMUNITY YOUR COMMUNITY
NOT MY COMMUNITY WHAT THE GUNS
ARE GOOD OR BAD GETS LOST IN THE
SHEER TRAUMA.
OF A LOST THE LIFE AT THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE HANGING OUT ON SPRING
BREAK.
LIKE ALL OF US HAD THE FREEDOM
AND LUXURY TO DO.
SOME MORE FREE TO DO SO THAN
OTHERS.
SO WHY TO RISE. TO LIFT UP THE
MEMORY OF THIS BRIGHT YOUNG STAR
A FUTURE [inaudible]
LEADER.
SOMEONE WHO HAD THE CREATIVITY
AND FOR THOUGHT. TWO ONE A
COMBINED BLACK STUDIES IN JAZZ
STUDIES THE HELP TOUCH A WHOLE
NEW GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE.
AND I RISE IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
MITCHELL.
SEEING NO OTHER MIKE'S.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON A FIRST --
SESSION HAVING PRESIDED UNDER
YOUR BELT.
I AND TO ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
PLEASE ENJOY THE WEEKEND AT HOME
WITH FAMILY AND LOVED ONES.
EVEN MORE SO GIVEN --
THE IN SESSION --
WE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT
TWO PM COLLEAGUES HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNED
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
AND AGAIN WE WILL RECONVENE HERE
MONDAYAT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND MEMBERS